i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
well big shocker guys the number of
assault rifles being purchased since the
recent shootings in texas and in buffalo
and in tulsa and all the other places
the number of assault rifles being
purchased is exploding and it is a
veritable
domestic arms race that is being faced
here and this should come as no surprise
to anyone who's been
watching the show listening to the
podcast for a while this is what happens
when there are shootings
and this is what happens when there are
not shootings i'll explain in a moment
let's go to video from uh gun shop in
georgia where the owner says
assault rifle sales are off the charts
and it's thanks to biden take a listen
to this the latest presidents are
driving this country everybody needs to
be caring at this point
at a firearms superstore in smyrna sales
are up 30 since last week assault rifle
sales have tripled says eric wallace and
especially first thing this morning
a lot of folks were waiting at the door
to purchase ar-15s ar-15 bands have
dominated discussions about gun sale
restrictions in light of their use in
recent mass shootings across the country
yet the assault rifle's deadly qualities
are also what draws gun enthusiasts
seeking a self-defense tool right if
you're dealing with a mob of people that
are trying to possibly take over your
home you're going to need and to protect
your family you're going to want as much
firepower as you can get
so i think it'd be a great choice
but why get an ar-15
oh well this america's rifle trevor
gainey walked out of the store with a
new ar-15. this is a good choice it's
you know it's what america's americans
choose to defend their homes with you
know
so you're buying it for home defense
uh not really
it's more of uh
more of a collector's item under imagine
that imagine that with anything else oh
wow that's a nice knife why this one
well it's the best knife for cutting oh
you're going to buy it for cutting
things no no no it's just a collectible
i don't actually plan to use it wait
what huh what are you talking about
some buyers say there is room for
greater government control over the
sales of firearms i think we do have to
have to have more stringent laws when it
comes to keeping guns out of the hands
of the mentally ill
this is crazy what's going on right now
but others view compromise on gun laws
as dangerous if we give up our second
amendment rights
we might just put the handcuffs on
everybody right it's like being in jail
if you can't have any gun you want at
any time with no oversight
it's like being in a prison now this
shouldn't surprise us i've said a
million times
more shootings generate gun sales in the
following way there's basically three
scenarios okay
you've got more shootings that make
national news and a democratic president
well you'd better go out and get those
guns because it's really dangerous out
there and the democratic president is
coming for your guns they never end up
coming for the guns but that's the story
so you've got shootings and a democratic
president increases in gun sales if
you've got shootings and a republican
president
then the republican president will
openly say
people should be defending themselves
it's dangerous out there so more
shootings than a republican president
also generate more gun sales and
on the off chance that we have a
decrease in shootings or or a temporary
lull although that's not very common in
the united states i mean we just have
shootings all the time but if we did
even on a localized level
then income the gun lobbies and they go
this is thanks
to people having guns
it is safer now because people have guns
so if you like that there are fewer
shootings if if that would ever happen
you'd better go and get yourself guns
because the
the more guns you have the safer you
will be so it doesn't happen it doesn't
matter what happens in the real world
in all three scenarios
more guns is what the gun lobby pushes
and the gun dealers and the gun
manufacturers no matter what they
justified and this is what we call you
come to your conclusion first and then
you find a different way to justify it
we want more guns
we can either justify it by saying more
guns have caused cause shootings to
decline so keep getting them or you need
guns because it's dangerous out there as
evidenced by all these shootings either
way the solution is more guns
uh asked on fox news why
uh gun deaths in the united states are
so much higher than in comparable
countries congressman steve scalise
blamed the defund the police movement
and unfortunately the fox news host in
question john roberts didn't even
attempt to push back so there's a lot
behind this and we've been talking about
the the senseless i mean just bizarre
justifications and explanations that
republicans and the pro-gun right have
given for why we have mass shootings in
the u.s and you don't see them in other
countries they've talked about covet
even though every country had coveted
video games doors they haven't gotten to
windows yet but maybe they they will uh
but this is a good question why why is
this a problem here and almost nowhere
else at least in terms of western
countries here is steve scalise attempt
at explaining it
let me move ahead to what's going on in
this country because in terms of the
developed world the united states far
and away leads every other nation in the
developed world true in terms of gun
violence hey and good for fox they put
up a chart showing how insanely higher
the rate of uh of gun violence deaths is
in the u.s than in any other country
good for fox for at least doing that
look at this graph the us way out in
front with four deaths per 100 000
people the next closest nation is cyprus
way behind at just below 0.7 deaths per
100 people
what do you think is responsible for
that discrepancy
well in a lot of those countries first
of all i mean you look at america in the
last couple of years you've seen this
crazy defund the police movement but
you've also seen a movement that's been
going on for a few years in big cities
where the da's aren't even prosecuting
criminals until it is a shooting or a
violent crime and
what what is this guy talking about
first of all
defund the police is a slogan almost no
departments have substantially defunded
anything some have reallocated funds
some have increased funding to police
but i'll think about another thing
the police departments in many of those
other countries on the list
are already more like the police
departments that the reform the police
movement wants anyway so think about
that they're saying the defund the
police movement is responsible it's a
slogan that's accomplished almost
nothing but if it did all it would do is
make police departments look more like
the police departments in italy uh in
france in other places where not
necessarily all officers have firearms
or you don't necessarily have an armed
response to every 9-1-1 goal but the
idea that
there are mass shootings
the mass shooters who they say are
mentally ill
are deciding whether to go and do
shootings
based on what da's are doing like it
it's completely incoherent letting
criminals back out on the streets and
inevitably what you see is higher rates
of crime
it's it's completely absurd these mass
shootings were not criminals that had
been left out but left back out on the
street let back out what you're also
seeing is more and more american
citizens law-abiding citizens are buying
guns to defend themselves but the
question was why do we have so many
shootings and he's saying well all these
citizens are buying guns to defend
themselves he's not trying to make that
point but he's almost inadvertently
making it more guns makes it more
dangerous it's happening in every
demographic group you can imagine where
you have large increases in people
buying guns because if they can't have
faith that their local police department
that's been defunded can arrive quickly
this guy's disgusting as you know barely
any any defunding has taken place and
it's just it's it's a slogan and blaming
the epidemic of gun violence on a slogan
that first of all is very new
defund the police as a widespread slogan
which by the way
almost no one on the left supports i
mean quite literally almost no one you
do polling most of the left wants to
reform the police they don't want to
defund it
that's what you're blaming it on and
what about all the mass shootings that
have taken place before that became a
slogan now i tweeted something similar
how do they explain it i tweeted quote
it would be interesting to figure out
why a country like italy for example has
essentially no mass shootings they have
economic problems they have diversity
you know sometimes the right life's to
say well
homogeneous countries have less violence
like countries like you know they often
point to norway or whatever
italy is a diverse country uh
what but they have almost no mass
shootings what could be the reason and
the great betsy brant who played marie
on breaking bad responded no one knows
of course tongue-in-cheek
the guns are the difference and people
jokingly responded and said well italy
has fresh pasta
italy doesn't have doors of course
that's a joke but in all seriousness
italy has doors and they have video
games and they had coveted mandates they
have everything other than as many guns
as we have per capita and they don't
have toxic american gun culture it's
both things
uh so any sensible person can see it's
pointing very strongly to the guns deal
with everything else sure but you've got
to deal with the guns as well now in
addition um the the the pointing fingers
at the defund the police movement you
know the the uvalde texas pd department
uh pd
police department was well funded and in
fact the police department there had 40
percent of the city's budget so think
about that 40 percent of the budget in
valdez is police
they have everything they need to go in
and stop a shooter
and they stood outside for an hour so at
least as far as that's concerned defund
the police a non-factor and steve
scalise is doing what they all do just
running interference that's all they
want to do they're not going to stop
they don't want to deal with guns in any
serious way and this is what you get by
the way
four five six mass shootings over the
weekend i mean we can't even keep track
at this point they didn't all make
national news
every day could just be the mass
shooting show where i just talk about
all we we would need multiple hours a
day to fully cover every mass shooting
in the united states
hey this is absolutely unbelievable
secret service was warned on the eve of
january 6 2021
that there would be a risk to mike pence
caused by donald trump
and his inciting
on january 5th and january 6. this is
this is truly incredible the secret
service assigned to mike pence warned
pence might be a target
because of trump
article on axios mark short the then
chief of staff to former vice president
mike pence warned the secret service
on january 5 of a security threat to
pence per the new york times the day
before the capital riot short warned his
top secret service agent tim geebles
that former president trump may turn
against pence and there could be a
security risk to pence because of it a
source with direct knowledge confirmed
to axios the report was accurate so both
axios and new york times independently
able to confirm this short did not have
knowledge of the specifics of the
security threat and it's not clear what
steps if any gibbels took to respond to
the warning the warning was the only
time that short flagged a security
concern during his time as pence's top
aide un understand what that uh what
that means okay
in the entire time that as vice
president mike pence had secret service
protection
there was never a specific threat
flagged to secret service by the pence
entourage or team
at the very end of the trump pence
regime
one such threat was communicated to
secret service and the reason for that
threat was donald trump the only threat
that pence's staff had to communicate to
secret service during the entire time
mike prince was vice president was one
precipitated by
and caused by his own president that
pence served under
think about that
uh cnn
had a report on this listen but also in
our politics lead new details today
about what the secret service was told
ahead of the january 6 insurrection and
of course it's mob chanting hang mike
pence hang mike pence according to the
new york times maggie haberman the vice
president's chief of staff mark short
warned pence's lead secret service agent
on january 5th
that donald trump could turn against the
vice president publicly and there could
be a security risk to the vice president
now also relevant is if they knew on
january 5th it's very clear that what
took place on the 6th was at least
expected and predicted by way more
people than they've admitted because of
it let's get let's get it from the
horse's mouth new york times reporter
maggie haberman who has uncovered this
for her upcoming book confidence man
which comes out in october maggie just
take a step back here i mean the idea
that the vice president's chief of staff
told the u.s secret service that the
president was going to be responsible
for a potential security risk to the
vice president i mean that's
quite something
it's remarkable jake and it's really not
a story about the secret service this is
a story about the enormous concern that
existed about the growing pressure that
donald trump was putting on his vice
president this extraordinary dynamic
where he was you know becoming
increasingly aggressive
in his commentary about a number of
officials but as he was trying to force
pence to essentially throw the electoral
college trump's way or at least back to
states on january 6th and the fact that
people in around pence recognized
that there was a potential safety risk
because of this because the former
president has this you know mob of of
very ardent supporters who follow what
he says now do i think now they uh of
course we're chanting hang mike pence at
a period of time on january 6 2021.
these are exactly the types of stories
that we said when trump left
it's going to take potentially years to
learn about all these things to some
degree because journalists are holding
it for their books and we've already
commented on that so i won't comment on
it again
the one threat
that had to be brought to pence's secret
service detail
originated from president trump let that
sink in send me your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds this has
happened to me before i've talked on the
show we got hacked it was costly it
wasn't a good feeling and that's why i
now protect myself with aura one of our
sponsors protecting your accounts and
devices gets complicated because you
need a bunch of different tools and aura
combines them all into one app identity
theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below
well we've finally gotten the results
amet oz the television doctor running in
the republican primary in pennsylvania
has won that republican primary and will
face the democratic primary winner john
fetterman dave mccormick the
candidate with whom oz was in a virtual
tie has conceded npr can now report dr
oz wins the senate primary in
pennsylvania after mccormick concedes
republican dave mccormick conceded
friday to celebrity dr mehmet oz in
pennsylvania's senate primary as the
state conducted a recount of the may 17
election according to the ap oz led
mccormick by 972 votes final results
were expected early next week in remarks
to supporters on friday mccormick said
he could not make up the deficit in the
recount today i called mehmet oz to
congratulate him on his victory said
mccormick and i told him what i always
told you i will do my part to try to
unite republicans and pennsylvanians
behind his candidacy behind his
nomination for senate of course oz was
endorsed by trump
oz tweeted i received a gracious phone
call from david mccormick and am
tremendously grateful for his pledge of
support in the fall election we share
the goal of a brighter future for
pennsylvania and america also relevant
and as a reminder we've covered this
fetterman is recovering from a stroke he
suffered days before the primary needed
to undergo a pacemaker implant procedure
has since not returned to the campaign
trail and has only done video
appearances since
um david brody from real america's voice
he tweeted as a result of this this
concession by dave mccormick all hail
the all-powerful trump
not sure i would be going with the hail
trump stuff myself last time i saw hale
trump it was richard spencer at a white
nationalist meeting
um
doing the hitler salute and saying hail
trump hail trump with people in the
crowd doing the same thing
in terms of the eventual
um general election race there's really
no good polling yet in terms of oz
versus fetterman pennsylvania senate oz
versus fetterman on real clear politics
they have it merely as a toss-up right
now and in 2016 the republican pat
toomey won by 1.6 in 2010 the republican
pat toomey won by two
this is an open seat now an open seat
and uh we are going to be very strongly
supporting john fetterman now this is an
opportunity to have a very real
conversation about the concentration of
resources and we dealt with this a
little bit last week on the
friday mailbag
there are endless races in which any of
us could invest time and or money
now
we want to
you never count anybody out you want to
support good candidates
but we also sometimes have to make hard
choices when there are limited resources
and i'm just going to give you an
example and i'm not telling you what to
do but this is a real question
marcus flowers is the challenger to
marjorie taylor greene in the georgia i
believe it's the 14th district that
green is uh running in
that's an outrageously red district
statistically it's very unlikely that
marcus flowers has a shot
but you could invest time and money in
that race as a progressive
you also have fetterman v oz in
pennsylvania
that race could quite literally decide
who controls the senate starting in
january of 2023. so i never say count
anyone out i never say don't work on on
races that are important to you
but at a certain point we also have to
consider that with limited resources
which which race is most likely to make
a difference
an almost certainly unwinnable race
against marjorie taylor green in the
georgia 14th
or the fetterman versus oz race in the
pennsylvania senate well i think that
the
the the facts tell us it's almost
certainly the latter so
just something to keep in mind as we go
forward here
peter navarro has been indicted by a
federal grand jury on criminal contempt
of congress charges for his refusal to
cooperate in the january 6th
investigation navarro lost it and trump
lost it as a result
now as a reminder peter navarro was an
economic adviser to trump
completely unhinged complete 2020 big
lie conspiracy guy
he was called in by the january 6th
committee refused to testify and he is
being held in criminal contempt he was
arrested he was cuffed he was booked now
jamie raskin told us they were going to
try to do this when i interviewed
congressman jamie raskin last week who's
on that committee he said we are
attempting to hold in contempt the
people who have refused to testify he
didn't mention peter navarro by name and
now here is peter navarro flipping out
at how he was treated instead of coming
to my door
where i live which by the way is right
next to the fbi
instead of calling me and say hey we
need you down at court
we've got a warrant for you i would have
gladly come what did they do
they intercepted me getting on the plane
and then they put me in handcuffs right
they bring me here they put me in leg
irons they stick me in a cell by the way
just historical mode i was in john
hinckley's cell they still think that
that was like a big time historical note
okay that's punitive that what they did
to me today
violated the constitution so he doesn't
like it and he's very very upset the
january 6th committee twitter published
a message about this saying quote while
today's indictment of peter navarro was
the correct decision by the justice
department we find the decision to
reward mark meadows and dan scavino for
their continued attack on the rule of
law puzzling they have also refused to
show up and have now as of now not yet
been arrested now trump lost it on his
platform truth social truth essential
donald trump publishing a message saying
wow
peter navarro our brilliant harvard
educated white house trade official by
the way the harvard thing
when they want to attack people
who went to harvard they go
liberal
indoctrinating wokester harvard well
harvard's bad but then when they want to
say hey why would they arrest one of our
guys and treat them like this they go he
went to harvard after all and you're
still treating him like this
story for a different day wow peter
navarro our brilliant harvard educated
white house trade official who was by
far the toughest advocate for tariffs
taxes and powerful right powerful
regulations on china was just handcuffed
shackled and put into prison because he
didn't obey the orders of the unselect
committee of political thugs
many of whom were involved with
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two the mueller reports scam
and of course the now fully debunked
russia russia russia
con
they've gone crazy so trump losing it
everybody losing it listen
you gotta show up that's it it's it you
just you've got to show up
they were told we will hold you in
contempt
they are doing it at least to some
people and we will see what happens next
as far as peter navarro is concerned but
the what jamie raskin told us they were
going to do
they're doing and every single one of
these people needs to be held
accountable hopefully this is the start
of that
hey this is a pretty big deal uh former
attorney general eric holder
is now predicting that donald trump and
his top administration officials will be
indicted will be indicted
uh newsweek writes former attorney
general eric holder predicted friday
that trump as well as other top
officials from the former president's
administration
will be invited by the uh indicted by
the u.s government over the events of
january 6 2021 and their efforts to
change the 2020 results in early may
holder told cbs news he believed trump's
actions related to january 6 merit an
indictment hundreds of trump supporters
attacked the u.s capitol that day after
the then president told them to walk to
the federal legislative building and
fight like hell to save their country
those directions came after trump
claimed for months that biden's victory
was fraudulent while pressuring
officials across the country to overturn
the win on friday in an interview on
hbo's real time with bill maher holder
reiterated his view that trump should
face indictment let's uh take a look at
this video
um of eric holder explaining this here
to bill maher on his show friday
if you were still the attorney general
about trump and january 6. well i'll
tell you if you'd asked me that question
uh about a year or so ago i would have
said i would have been awfully concerned
about the divisive nature of bringing a
case against a former president but now
because of what we know what great
journalists have done the leaks that
have come from the january 6th committee
if you show me that donald trump was
involved in the efforts to
in essence foment a coup and you can
show the requisite intent
he has to be indicted
and what would that entail after you
indict him
after you indict him well he would then
you know you take him to trial just like
anybody else i think you know you can
look at what merrick garland is going to
do
i think my primary my first
analysis would be what's going to happen
to him in georgia right you've got him
on tape saying you know find me eleven
thousand seven hundred eighty-four that
is close to a layup it seems to
me i've always said the same thing about
that why don't they just go after that
one moment it's on tape you have the
smoking gun he's saying
i mean i remember when rod blagojevich
was on tape
basically it didn't work out too well
for him no i know but but it was it was
it was it was pretty blatant but it
wasn't as bad as find me 11 000 votes
yeah yeah no i think as i said i think
that's close to a layup uh the d.a down
there is going to be calling witnesses i
understand before a special grand jury
but the interesting thing there is that
that can also be a specification and a
federal charge that could be brought in
washington d.c when you're charging him
with conspiracy to defraud and con
conspiracy to obstruct what happened in
georgia can actually be part of a
federal case as well so i think you know
i was a federal prosecutor doing
political corruption cases when i first
came to the justice department for 12
years and you get a feel for these
things after a while
i get the feeling that i can see where
this one is going and a lot of high
level people in the trump administration
i suspect the president himself people
at the justice department are all going
to find themselves
on a little document that says the
united states versus fill in the blame
so there is the prediction and the hope
would be
that the department of justice will view
the upcoming january 6th hearings which
start later this week
as a way to say well now we see it all
in detail and while the main purpose of
the january 6 committee is not criminal
investigation
if they uncover we've talked about this
before if they un cover criminal
activity they refer to the justice
department to look at it and what eric
holder is saying is how the how could
they come to any other conclusion now
there are some who will say the hearings
are sort of uh embarrassing enough that
you don't need to indict that's like the
prototypical susan collins thing
republican senator susan collins loves
to say well i was very disappointed that
they incited the riotous insurrection
but the hearings were embarrassing
enough to them and that's enough
punishment we don't need to make this a
political show trial i'm sure they would
never do it again they've learned their
lesson that's the susan collins approach
you'll probably hear that from some
in the coming weeks after we see what
the january 6 committee has which will
be fascinating to see we'll have these
clips on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount join
pacman.com
we've just learned that the upcoming
january 6 trump riot committee hearings
which start thursday night in prime time
will reportedly include video of
testimony from donald trump's daughter
ivanka trump and of testimony from
donald trump's son-in-law ivanka's
husband jared kushner both key players
in the trump administration now this may
not achieve anything
but it should serve to shed some serious
light
on what took place we're going to look
at the new report about this remember
that jamie raskin last week told us
we are we are bringing the heat we are
going to be exposing some serious things
during these committee hearings
and then there's a question of who we'll
be watching but we'll talk about that in
a moment huffington post report january
6th panel to reportedly air ivanka trump
and jared kushner videotapes the house
select committee investigating last
year's insurrection is gearing up for
its national debut of hearings that will
include videotaped interviews with
ivanka trump and jared kushner per the
washington post on thursday select
committee chair benny thompson and vice
chair liz chaney will launch the series
of televised hearings featuring both
live witnesses and taped interviews
including several white house figures
both trump and kushner served as senior
advisors in donald trump's white house
during the insurrection last year
their interviews have been described to
the post as gripping
i think we don't have any idea how
insane these hearings are going to be
yet the committee will attempt to place
the violence at the capitol on january
6th in a broader context of a
wide-ranging scheme to overturn a
legitimate presidential election with
trump's involvement serving as the
through line cassidy hutchinson a top
aide to the former white house chief of
staff mark meadows is expected to play a
key role she's already reportedly
provided the committee with extensive
information about meadows activities
aimed at overturning the election the
final hearing will focus mainly on trump
what he did and what he said before and
on january 6th any remaining bombshells
will be revealed by then
this is a very very big deal
now will anybody be watching these
hearings
i don't know
uh
it's
you know if a tenth of the adult
population were to watch it live i'd i'd
be surprised i'm not particularly
optimistic right now that this is going
to garner the large mainstream audience
i think in our world this is going to be
huge for people who follow shows like
ours
and i want this to break through into
the mainstream i wish we didn't have
circumstances where lots of people are
fine either having no idea what happens
at such a hearing or
being told by fox news the next day what
took place because we can guess that the
story that the mainstream media will
tell will be at best incomplete and the
story that right-wing weaponized media
like fox news newsmax and oan will tell
will be actively deceptive it will
likely get a lot of media coverage but
the question is how much interest will
there be from americans in the hearings
themselves the
primary sources as i like to call them
and unfortunately we have this status
quo in the united states where you've
got a lot of
dis casually right-wing disinterested
americans who
aren't interested in watching something
for hours
but are very happy to be told the next
morning on fox and friends by pete
hegseth or ainsley earhart what they
should believe about what took place and
you can expect that they are going to
say
because they're already sort of saying
it these hearings are a distraction well
from what the hearings are a distraction
from the real stories
biden inflation
biden gas prices
biden formula shortage
the
biden failure in ukraine
uh do you know what is it the the audit
going on in whatever state there's even
still an audit going on and so at the
end of the day the core question we care
about
is what might come from the hearings the
hope would be
just obvious overwhelming evidence of
criminality that the justice department
can't ignore the the dream scenario
would be what is presented in prime time
for everybody who wants to see it to see
is so
undeniably criminal in what it exposes
that the doj
has to take it up that's the dream
uh and that's what we talked about
earlier in the context of former
attorney general eric holder saying
that's what he expects not everybody is
expecting that but that's what eric
holder expects
this is not particularly good news for
donald trump ron desantis has again
defeated donald trump in another one of
these 2024 republican straw polls now
the straw poll is a little different
than the normal polls that we talk about
when we talk about presidential
elections so let me explain to you
what's going on newsweek reporting trump
loses to desantis in 2024 straw poll at
conservative summit again
florida's governor ron desantis was
favored for a second year over former
president donald trump to be the
republican party's 2024 presidential
nominee at a conservative conference
this was held in colorado it's the
western conservative summit they always
do these straw polls now if we look at
the results
you will see that this is a picture of
the screen at the event
these numbers don't add up to 100. so
ron desantis coming in first at 71
percent and donald trump coming in
second at just under 68 then you've got
ted cruz ben carson sarah huckabee
sanders tim scott mike pompeo
donald trump jr nikki haley and mike
pence why don't they add up to a hundred
voters are allowed to make more than one
choice this is what's called an approval
poll and i think there's even a yeah
newsweek has a paragraph about this
because voters were allowed to make more
than one choice through the approval
voting method the percentages add up to
more than 100 percent
this minimizes spoilers and sabotage and
gives viability and visibility to my
minor candidates so the idea here is you
just check off who would you approve of
being the nominee
and more people approve of desantis
being the republican nominee than trump
but not by much
now what's very interesting to follow
about this is that trump and desantis
are already feuding for the most part
every once in a while they'll say
something polite about the other but
this all started when ron desantis
refused to rule out that he'd run
against trump in 2024. trump has no
problem i guess with desantis saying
if trump didn't run i would consider
running i would bow down at the altar of
trump and let trump have it if trump
wants it if trump doesn't want it i'd
consider it but desantis didn't rule out
running against trump he didn't say i'm
planning to do it but he didn't rule it
out
this we had reports of months ago which
we talked about in some detail
sent trump for a tailspin trump now
hates desantis and desantis has also
started to distance from trump desantis
has started saying i shouldn't have
listened to trump so much early on in
the pandemic i don't remember him
listening very much to trump to be
honest but that's what desantis has said
and trump has been saying desantis
benefited from my help early in the
pandemic and they're no longer getting
along with each other so we're going to
follow these numbers very closely but
maybe the most interesting thing about
all of this
is that we are now seeing the closest
numbers we have ever seen in the betting
markets for who will be the republican
nominee if you go to predictive.org
um
what these numbers show us are
how much money do you need to bet
to win a dollar so basically the more
you need to bet to win a dollar
uh the more likely that outcome is
because that's how odds work these
numbers are as close as they've ever
been donald trump is now at 38 cents
and ron desantis is now at 34 cents
this is the closest they've ever been
they at one point they were much further
apart and in fact if you look at
uh the ron desantis numbers here if i
can pull them up oh i guess i have to be
logged in in order to do that
uh
oh okay here we go so if you look here
at um
trump and desantis
they oh this is not even close enough
here we go so as you can see the numbers
have gotten closer and closer early in
march you had trump 39 and desantis 27
separated by 12. and as you can see
mostly as a result of desantis
consolidating support from other
candidates without trump really
declining much
they are now almost tied and remember
this isn't who would you vote for this
is who do you believe will be the
nominee we have never seen it this close
in terms of us on the left what do we
care about
we care about whatever scenario
gets us to something other than trump or
pence as president in 2024
i don't really care who the nominee is
as long as they end up losing now of
course at a certain point we would ask
the question which nominee is more
likely to lose is it trump or is it
pence i don't know the answer yet
we don't have great polling on that yet
although i expect it to start soon and
definitely after the midterms
if trump would be easier to beat
i'd rather it be trump
if desantis would be easier to beat i'd
rather it be desantis the x factor is
desantis is less incompetent than trump
and that probably makes him more
dangerous because he might be better
able to get things done this is a
conversation we will have time for but
those are the latest numbers
desantis looking increasingly strong
against trump i want to hear from you
leave a comment send an email send a
tweet
who would you rather the democratic
nominee run against would you rather run
against trump or would you rather run
against desantis let me know we'll do a
follow-up
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support
the show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's check
out a sort of good old-fashioned
conspiracy theory this one combines the
globalish you know how alex jones always
uses that term globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike obama trudeau mccrone
and the rest of these zio beasts
that's a recording of me doing alex
jones okay so one america news oan
anchor alison steinberg
did a globalist rant about globalists
tracking her
through her apartments i guess it's a
nest thermostat
with its energy-saving settings
this is um yeah let's just take a look
at this and this is the level of
delusion that now is being uh that that
we're now seeing presented in a serious
manner all right so i think it's pretty
obvious we can all agree the whole goal
with these globalists is to track us and
trace us and monitor every single thing
that we do in our everyday lives in fact
this device that you're probably
watching me from that you're holding in
your hand is doing just that right now
and we know this this is not new news
okay however i've just discovered
another layer of this story that is
what i believe taking it a step
way too far so i just moved into this
new place and this nest device came
automatically installed uh-oh
with the apartment it's the
thermostat control basically so it's
really cold in here because there's
cement floors and i
was constantly having to turn the heat
up
now
i realized
it would get cold after i turned the
heat up
this is this is just the best i hope you
guys see where this is going on multiple
occasions so i started thinking why is
this happening now get this i'm going to
show you the
interface of this and you're not going
to believe it okay so i'm having to turn
it up again because it went down to 70
and i wanted it at 73.
so it's having to heat up
again
so my old place when i when i lived in
boston my old place had these
and
when my tenants came in the same thing
happened and they didn't ascribe it to
the globalist they ascribed it to the
how the technology works and i'll tell
you how you fix this this this is the
best and because it keeps turning itself
back down and i was wondering why is
this happening well i decided to go to
settings
and then i found this home away assist
then it says automatically use eco
temperatures when no one's home so that
means this thing
can track whether or not i'm in my
house yeah now
nest thermostats
they have a proximity sensor so like
when you walk by it
it turns on so you don't have to press
it like if you want to just see what the
temperature is you walk by and it senses
you walk by and it flips on and you go
oh it's 72 so you don't have to click it
or press it and it uses that to figure
out whether you're likely home or not
so this thing was turning itself off
when i wasn't home and then would
automatically start reheating when it
sensed i was back inside it must be the
globalist and if that's not creepy
enough they also somehow now have my
email address because they keep
harassing me in my inbox to sign up for
their stupid app so it can connect to my
phone their stupid app can track me even
further this is absolute madness if you
have a nest turn off all these settings
because it's taking it way too far yeah
you can turn off all of these settings i
mean
listen uh at one point i started to
suspect that the milk frother attachment
on my espresso machine had a camera in
it and an rfid chip because every time i
made an espresso i would get an email
offering me a coffee based vaccine it
was crazy but then i realized no i'm
wrong i'm an idiot could she really
believe this all of these thermostats
have these functions
the thermostats
when i when i left my place in boston
and tenants came in
i didn't use almost any of these things
because i had turned them off i i like
to control everything manually you know
i'm like there's just types some people
are like set it to automatic and let it
do it thing in the car with climate
control i don't want to control the fan
speed and i just go i want 72 auto you
figure out how to get us to auto it's
out of 72.
at home
i'm sort of more aware of like okay when
am i usually going to bed and i want it
cooler
so i turn all of this stuff up this
stuff off i don't want the temperature
changing when i'm in and out i already
am using more like eco-friendly
temperatures during the day when i'm out
at work you know all these different
things
so
when my tenants turned it on they were
like hey it's not doing anything and i
said well you've got to let it learn i
never used that so you've got to let it
learn your schedule and it's a smart
thermostat you just turn it off there's
no globalist
globalist yeah it's just the way the
technology is designed and i it's hard
for me to know for sure
whether what you just saw is serious i i
just don't know
it's very sick if it is
but maybe it's just trolling that's
allison steinberg from one american news
news network you can just turn all that
stuff off george soros won't have any
say
uh klaus schwab because remember i know
her i know this is allison steinberg so
she may be jewish herself i've never met
anyone named steinberg who's not jewish
but globalish usually is talking about
rich jewish men who want to control
everything including uh the fan speed
apparently now on your ac very wild
stuff and my question to you is simply
do you think she's for real or do you
think she's just playing this up for her
audience
last week i told you about two
republicans who said
it's too much with the shootings
we need gun control i'm open
to an assault weapons ban that was adam
kinzinger republican congressman who's
outgoing and new york's chris jacobs
one of those two republicans has now
been so shunned by the republican party
that has withdrawn their support for him
that he now has announced he's not going
to be running for reelection that's it
you're off script and you're gone so
reminder last week i did a story called
multiple republicans changed their minds
open to banning assault rifles
and they weren't like huge lefty
declarations it was just hey you know
i've opposed these types of bans in the
past
but we sort of have to do something
because this isn't good
and one of those republicans was chris
jacobs from new york he is now done
here's a report from the hill
new york republican won't run for second
term after backing gun control
representative chris jacobs on friday
announced he will not run for a second
term in the house one week after
breaking from his party and announcing
his support for an assault weapons ban
jacobs who represents suburbs of buffalo
said today i'm announcing i will not run
for the 23rd congressional district i
will finish out my time as a member of
congress to the end of this year
jacobs was endorsed by the nra in 2020
announced he would support a bill to ban
assault style rifles if it came to the
floor adam kinzinger who's retiring said
the same thing
jacobs also backed raising the required
age for specific gun sales to 21 years
old i'd say 25 but 21 something enacting
a federal limit on gun magazine
capacities i agree and prohibiting the
sale of body armor to the public the new
york republican told the buffalo news in
an interview that he reconsidered his
point of view toward guns after the
shootings in buffalo and uvalde texas
makes sense
jacobs on friday said every republican
elected official who endorsed him in his
re-election bid has withdrawn their
support since he backed gun control
measures last week he also said he lost
the backing of republican committees and
the republican and conservative parties
in new york state
the congressman said he ultimately
decided to back out of the race to avoid
an incredibly divisive election despite
the backlash i truly believe i could win
but it would be incredibly divisive for
the party and the people of the 23rd
district many of whom i have not ever
uh represented
um this is because the redistricting
would move him from the 27th to the 23rd
district saying he doesn't want a
campaign filled with half-truths and
lies so look at that he merely
entertains an assault weapons ban and he
is excommunicated by the party and is
driven out of office now i know some
people will say but david he chose to
quit okay but the message here is
if you aren't on message we all pull our
support we endorse your opponent you're
on your own there's no gray area on this
issue you're either on script or you
were off script it's a form of
you guys know what it is right
it's a form of cancel culture
you say one wrong thing
and you're out
and any sort of moderation
puts you in a precarious position in
today's republican party it's not a big
tent party there i mean think of it liz
cheney all she said was trump genuinely
lost biden genuinely won trump did have
a role in inciting the insurrection
she's on a list she gets primaried trump
shows up and campaigns for her opponent
so this is how they work don't let them
trick you into believing
that the canceled culture is on the left
they will cancel you
if you go off script right away and this
is evidence of it so the two thing to
think of it the two republicans who have
said hey you know what
this was my view before
but here's my view now
um kenzinger is saying it with the
safety of knowing he's retiring anyway
and jacobs now is saying whoa this got
crazy i'm bailing
sad commentary on the state of the
republican party
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
here's a caller commenting on fox news
host laura ingram last week
linking cannabis to mass shootings take
a listen to this
hey david
susan from chicago coming commenting on
laura ingram and her
ridiculous marijuana
conclusions
um i can assure you that people who
smoke marijuana are not out committing
crimes we are at home eating frozen
cookie dough in our pajamas so
keep that in mind
and uh have a nice day yeah and of
course this the stereotype of the
cannabis user
is
relaxed low-key
not out there committing violent crimes
and generally speaking that's accurate
there are some studies we've talked
about which can link
cannabis to uh people kind of
predisposed to aggressive behavior in
some of them there have been some
studies that say cannabis can sort of
enliven that tendency but no evidence
whatsoever of a causal relationship
between cannabis and violent crime
that's what the facts and the best
studies we have tell us as of right now
i don't even know that laura ingram
really believes it
but it's certainly something i mean
listen they'll latch on to anything for
the first few days after the texas
shooting it was doors too many doors
open doors unlocked doors
then it shifted to other things well
it's mental illness but you guys always
vote against funding for mental illness
well so it's probably some other thing
maybe now it's cannabis cannabis
psychosis is another thing they're
pointing to their only goal is
don't talk about guns that's the one
piece we can't talk about anything else
they'll blow smoke up your you know
wherever in your nostrils but the gun
piece you can't talk about we'll see uh
what happens over the next week with
this forthcoming vote in the house on
banning assault weapons
can democrats find 10 republicans in the
senate to get to 60
and would they have the votes of all 50
democrats is also a fair question
uh to pass an assault weapons ban i
think by friday we'll have a much better
idea we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today among other stories we will
talk about the supreme court deciding to
allow states to use illegally
gerrymandered republican districting
maps
in the 2022 midterm elections what why
we will talk about that and much more on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and remember that you can use the coupon
code big voting 22. surrounded by
water big water not big water just big
voting big voting 22 to get a discount
off of a membership at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below